for the second time in his presidency
Donald Trump has authorized a military
strike against Syria in response to the
Assad regime's apparent use of chemical
weapons on its citizens one week ago
last night skies over the capital
Damascus lit up as US British and French
warplanes launched airstrikes against
suspected chemical weapons research and
storage facilities the operation was
twice the size of the one launched a
year ago against a Syrian airfield
President Trump announced the attacks
from the White House late last night
he describes Syrian President Bashar
al-assad as a monster mr. Trump also had
a message for two of Syria's biggest
supporters to Iran and to Russia I asked
what kind of a nation wants to be
associated with the mass murder of
innocent men women and children mr.
Trump also said deterring the use of
chemical weapons is vital to national
security Seth Doane is the only US
network correspondent in Syria but our
coverage will begin this morning with
David Martin live at the Pentagon David
good morning good morning this strike
came after a week of speculation about
what President Trump would do in
response to last Saturday's chemical
attack it's the second time he has
retaliated against Syria for its use of
chemical weapons only this time the US
did not fight alone
British Jews could be seen taking off
from the island of Cyprus at the
beginning of a raid in which the US and
its allies fired more than 120
precision-guided weapons tonight France
the United Kingdom and the United States
took decisive action to strike the
Syrian chemical weapons infrastructure
with British and French officers at his
side defense secretary Mathers said the
strikes were a one-time shot in
retaliation for last weekend's chemical
attack on civilians in a suburb of
Damascus long-range missiles were fired
from ships submarines and aircraft at
targets in the Syrian capital of
Damascus and near the city of Homs in
port and infrastructure was destroyed
which will result in a setback for the
Syrian regime they will lose years of
research and development data
specialized equipment inexpensive
chemical weapons precursors Joint Chiefs
chairman General Joseph Dunford
described the targets the first target
was a scientific research center located
in the greater Damascus area this
military facility was a Syrian Centre
for the research development production
and testing of chemical and biological
warfare technology Dunford said the
missiles also struck targets where the
ingredients for the chemical weapons
were stored and mixed the second target
was a chemical weapons storage facility
west of Homs we assessed that this was
the primary location of Syrian sarin and
precursor production equipment the third
target which was in the vicinity of the
second target contained both a chemical
weapons equipment storage facility and
an important command post Dunford said
the targets were chosen to minimize
civilian casualties and to avoid hitting
Russian forces based in Syria the
Russians were not given any specific
warning that a strike was coming the
Russian ambassador to the US condemned
the strikes saying we warned that such
actions will not be left without
consequences a US official says all
aircraft returned safely to their bases
intelligence analysts are still
examining reconnaissance photos to
determine whether the targets were
completely destroyed
Greenup David Martin at the Pentagon
David thank you